OUOTED
NO
>> SHE JUST LOS PETHESE DAYS AND
CAPITOL, JANUARY 6 COULD HAVE
RS
MICHAEL FANONE.
AS BRUTALLD MULTIPLE
MES. PART OF THE FOOTAGE.
OFFICER FANE WT BAO
PILL TO TALK TO EM.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING.
>> THANKME ON.>>HA YOU.
>> WHY DOU GO TALK TO THEM WER?
>> SO, I JUST WENTHESC
G THE S.E 21 MEM  VO FOR THGO ML
CAPITOL POLICE OAS THE MFICERS D
RECTIO JANUARY
I  THERE WITH THEM, TALK TO THEY
FOOTAGE IF TY ESTED.
JUSTELAY W
WERE ANDS OF
COLLEAGUES.
WERE I DIDN'T GO THERE WITTHE T
BUNCH OFWANTEDBETTERDU THEM
AS TO WHAT OFFICERS' EXPIE
THADAY.NO DIDN'T MEET
WITH ANYRS OTHERI
DID BUMP INTO N ANVAR.>> LOUT.
THISOU RANNT
CONGRESSMAN ANDREW
HERE'S WHAT HE SAID ABOUT TCH T.
S NOURIDN'T KNOW THE TV FOOTAGA
NOW.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAN SEE
I THINK YOU'RE IN TH
IC ON JANUARY 6th
WHICH CLEARLY DN BE
CESSARY  JAL
SO WHAT HAPPENED WHEN YOU
INTRODUCED YOURSELF TO THE NGRE
I WAS THERE WITHER HAR ACCOMPANM
THUG CAPITOL.
I WENT GREETED CONGRESSMAN
CLYDE.
I  CORDIAL.
I EXTENDED MY HAND
HE JUST STARED AT ME.
I ASKED IF HE WAS GOING TO SHAKE
MY HAND AND HE SAID HE DIDN'T
WHO KNOW IAS
UCEDSAID I WAS MICHAEL
THAT I WAS A D. METROPOLITANFFI
SU A TRAUMATIC
INJURY AS WELL AS A HEART ATTACS
TIMES AT THE BASE OF MY SKULL,
AS WASEL
BEATEN.
TURNED AWAY CONGRE
D OUT A CE PHONE.
IT LOOKEE WAATTEMPTINGUP LIKE A
OPENED, HE RAN AKLE KE AARD. LA.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK OTHAT?
TOARINTERACT
OOK IT AS F ANEW
GIVING THE MIDDLE FINGER TO
MYSELFNDER
DEPARTME ACAL AN
WE HAVEN'T HEARDTHATAY>> WE REA.
FUMBLINGH HIS PHTRRIGHT.
WH ME   EXPLAINED WHO I WAS
JAAR NEITHER ONE OF US
SPOKE TOACTHAT
O RECORD AL OUT HIS PHONE.PPENE
KNOW, I FELTONFRONM SPECIFICALLE
BILL, THEY HAD, WHETHER
IT WAS LANGUE, CONGRESSMAN
CLYDE HAMAE PRET EMARKSNPLAYITH
HE JUST AND OUT LIHIPOF YOU'
LI BB JANUARY 6t
T ONT.
AND YOU'RE GOING TO BE HELD BLE.
YOU BEING THERE?
COMPLAINING ABOUT YOU BEING ON
THE HILL?
THERO
I'M SUREWE
ABOUT YOU BEIN
6, B GO ON.OF OUR IER
STF MEMBERS.E WE
INIBDI.
TOSS IOWKNOW, WA
ETH MEMBOF
REPRESENTATIVES.
E
EXLIKEGNICREN HAVING A SITDOWN
WITH T RREWE DID HAVE RACTION W.
I ER HIST HIS CHATHIS CHIEFF
SEEMED
AT OUR PSEE AT OFF
AND I BELIEVE THE THERE
DISCUSS JANUARY 6th.
WE WERE ORDIAL THERE WAS
POTENTIAL FOR SOME DEGREE
LITY MERE PRHE
HE PEOPLE
THAT THE INTERACTIONS AND T OLI.
I THINK SOMEBERS, DR, AND THIS R